WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi, I'm Wayne
Piekarski for the Developer
Show, and this is your update
on the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
.app is the newest top-level
domain from Google Registry
and it's now open for
general registration.
The link's on the post
in the description below.
If you're heading
to WWDC this year,
join us at the Firebase
party on June 4
to hang out with
other developers,
meet engineers and product
leads from the Firebase team,
and relax after the
first day of WWDC.
Head on over to the post
to request an invite.
On Google Cloud
platform, alias IPs
allow you to configure
secondary IPs or IP
ranges on your virtual
machine instances
for a secure and highly
scalable way to deliver traffic
to your applications.
You can now dynamically add
and remove alias IP ranges
for existing running
VMs so that you
can migrate your
applications from one VM
to another in the event of
a software machine failure.
[INAUDIBLE] and example
commands are on the post.
We've rolled out the next
generation schedule for App
Engine standard
environment, and our tests
showed that it delivers
better scaling performance,
more efficient
resource consumption,
and lower costs for you.
Check out the post for metrics
and links to get started.
Logs contain some of
the most valuable data
available, particularly when
troubleshooting an incident,
and structured log data
is even more powerful,
enabling you to extract the most
valuable data from your logs.
We recently announced
new features
so that you can better
use structured log
data, such as the ability to add
custom fields in logs if you're
in Stackdriver.
Take a look at the post
for screenshots and steps
to get started.
HTTPS usage on the
web has taken off
as we've evolved Chrome
security indicators.
Later this year, we'll be
taking several more steps
along this path.
To learn more about the
changes and to get the link
to our setup guides for HTTPS,
head on over to the post.
Over one billion
people in the world
have some form of disability.
Building products
that don't consider
a diverse range of
needs could mean
missing a substantial group of
potential users and customers.
But don't worry,
we're here to help.
We recently launched a
new suite of resources
to help you make your products
and designs more accessible,
and links to those
resources are in the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Wayne Piekarski
for the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]